this is Startalk hi I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson I'm an astrophysicist with the
American Museum of Natural History and
I'm host of star talk radio welcome back
to star talk radio and it's fighting all
these air molecules like what's up with
that we win astrophysicist if I'm
traveling through the universe and I see
a black hole coming I'm going there okay
and interstellar they had Matthew
McConaughey interacting with his time
line so the premise was you go into a
black hole you have access to these
higher dimensions but starting back in
ordinary life we have three dimensions
that we're familiar with on a grid you
might think of it is what's Street in
New York what's Street what haven't you
and what floor in a building that you
might meet someone these are three
coordinates that you would give remember
however that anytime you've ever made an
appointment to see someone yes you are
yes you are would not give a time
without a place nor would you give a
place without a time so the actual
coordinates to meet someone require four
numbers basically four coordinates three
space coordinates and one time George
you never said to your friend I'll meet
you at 10 o'clock tomorrow where you
never saw I'll meet you at the corner of
33rd and 3rd when we know intuitively
that we need a space in a time
coordinate combined in order to have
life unfold in any meaningful way so the
idea that we live in four dimensions
should not be surprising to people we
take it for granted actually
but the difference is that we are not
prisoners of our three-dimensional space
I can walk left and right I can jump up
and down I can walk forwards and
backwards and I can repeat that I can
access all points of my
three-dimensional space yet I am a
prisoner in the present forever
transitioning from the past into the
future I have no access to the past I
have no access to the future and so if
you go to a higher dimension it's not
unrealistic to think that you step out
of the time dimension and now you look
at time as though we look at space so
very questions that we have very
statements that we make about our lives
make no sense in that higher coordinate
system you connects when was I born well
you're always born when did I go to
college you're always going to college
when did I die
you're always dying and so if your whole
timeline is laid out in front of you
then you have access to it and you can
jump in at any point relive it we don't
know yet if you can interfere with
events that quote have already happened
if your whole timeline is just already
there what does it mean to jump into it
and then change something if it's
already there so these are fascinating
questions that make great fodder for
science fiction stories and we don't
know what's in a black hole so take it
and run with it
you